hey Seto files welcome to movie clips
Oscar recap I'm Jes I'm Ryan and I'm Sam
and we're talking about last night's
ceremony the winners the losers all that
good stuff
yeah the let's just start with the
ceremony okay it was not especially
entertaining but not terrible I thought
that one DeGeneres did a fine job she
played it very safe yeah yeah that she
cut a little deep sometimes it was like
halfway between Ricky Gervais and the
most benign and imagined I think that's
called Billy Crystal yeah yes crystal
America also completely locked out a
temporary which like you know a couple
of months ago everybody was saying the
other movies are too out there they're
too confrontational American hustle is a
little sort of like you know it's it's
well-made but it's kind of whoopee and
like you know everybody can kind of
watch it it doesn't you know demand that
your viewpoint be changed yeah and
nothing gravity and twelve years are the
big winners that yeah they're surprising
not surprising at all I'm a little
surprised that Steve McQueen didn't win
Best Director but I I thought that was
going to Quran yeah put a bullet it
makes sense because the technical thing
they kind of like to award technical
achievements with directors especially
just speaking about some memorable
moments for the night the first thing
that jumps to mind for me it was small
and like if you blink you would have
missed it but Bill Murray did like a
really had a really nice moment for
Harold Ramis and knowing kind of the
legend of Bill Murray being a guy who
never really shows any kind of sentiment
yeah Lupita Nyong'o
she's from 12 years a slave had a
beautiful touching eloquent speech that
I thought really really stood out yeah
she was very inspiring and gracious I
loved seeing her up there Matthew
McConaughey who want for Best Actor
which was not a surprise at all okay
the culmination of four years the
Matthew McConaughey Renaissance makan
hog and it you could tell that they
clearly were willing to give him as much
time oh yeah and he could have gone on
forever but again it's kind of cool to
see occasionally people put aside the
sort of feigned surprise that they have
when they get up there and like oh I
don't even know you know who to think
and he just clearly rehearsed this in
front of a mirror
yeah I'm just when he was home but he
was play to make a great speech guys I
can't wait to see Matthew McConaughey in
ten years
yeah Jared Leto also had a beautiful
acceptance speech any any upsets guys
because I have a few really yeah shares
okay the upset that I'm sure you'll want
to talk about yeah is the win for 20
feet from STAR Labs early
act of killing which I was a little
surprised by but again it does feel like
both that's the Oscar pick it's been a
great year for movies and absolutely
everything deserved to be on the slate
and it was just so like it was it was a
great feeling just looking at all these
movies and there's no you know give me
give me an Oscar films among the Slade
so yeah I mean overall good Oscar cast I
thought that that Ellen DeGeneres was
awesome as always she's so charming and
um not that many surprises know him but
comment below and let us know what you
thought of the Oscars and if you thought
that there were any huge upsets we're
really curious to know what people think
until next time I'm right I'm Jay S exam
thank you for watching
you